Speaker 1: Let's take a look at the downward
spiral of the children of Trump over the last
few days since we learned of the Trump indictment.
We are not going to be talking about Ivanka here.
Ivanka just put out kind of a very short statement
on Instagram saying she's heard from people all
over the political spectrum concerned about
what's going on. Very, very vague. Ivanka
does seem to be wanting to stay far from politics
after the disaster of her first first four years
of involvement in politics. We then go to Donald
Trump Jr, who now has a show on rumble and the
downward spiral really continues. It's actually
kind of getting sad. And listen, I'm sure it is
very difficult for your father to be indicted. I'm
sure it is. Also, it's not you know, we know that
Trump doesn't seem necessarily to be the biggest
fan of his adult male children, but that's another
story. Anyway, here is Don Jr Just dissembling.
Speaker 4: This is clearly an attempt to
intimidate a journalist. And yet the rest
of journalism, the rest of the media,
strangely silent guys, listen.
Maybe coincidence has happened,
but not anymore. In 2023. I don't believe in this
much coincidence. And if you've been watching
literally anything for the last six years, you
shouldn't either. The fact that the IRS showed
up at Matt Taibbi House on the same day that
he testified before Congress and their new
committee investigating the weaponization of
the federal government is a little bit beyond
ironic, not suspicious. It's absolutely insane.
Okay. Matt Taibbi is opening statement on the
Twitter files. Twitter, Facebook, Google and
other companies develop a formal system for
taking in moderation requests from every corner
of government FBI, DHS, HHS, D.O.D., the Global
Engagement Center, etc., etc. That's his opening
line. And we think that it's a coincidence
that the IRS knocks on his door that day.
Speaker 1: All right. So what this all has
to do with Donald Trump is unclear why Junior's
eyes are almost completely swollen shut. We don't
know. That seems to be similar to his own dad. And
here is donald trump jr during his rumble show,
really just furious about this entire thing.
Speaker 4: I was proven even more right
than i would have ever imagined.
Speaker 1: Is that even possible
that nobody's been more right
than Don Jr About everything, I guess.
Speaker 4: Apparently you know Soros to back
Manhattan District Attorney Alvin Bragg.
Speaker 1: And again I don't know what he
says saw roast back but if he means George Soros
backed we've looked at this in detail remember
George Soros funds hundreds of programs. One
of the programs George Soros funds is a PAC
that helps to get DA's elected. One of the days
that was helped by that PAC is Alvin Bragg. There
has never been any contact between Alvin Alvin
Bragg and George Soros. There has never been any
communication one way or the other about a Trump
investigation. That's the connection that they're
talking about. They want you to think Soros is
calling Alvin Bragg and saying, Indict Trump.
Speaker 4: Is actually indicting my father.
So let's be clear, folks. Yeah, this is.
Like communist level fascist stuff that would
make Mao, Stalin, Pol Pot. It would make them
blush. It's so flagrant. It's so crazed when
even like the radical leftist of the Washington
Post are out there saying it's not really based
on fact, it's not really based on the law, it's
not really based in reality, but it's 100% based
on politics when your enemies are saying that.
It's got to tell you everything you need to
know right now about where we are as a country.
Speaker 1: Yeah, where we are. As it turns out
that the one man crime spree that was Donald Trump
isn't above the law just because he was president.
That's what it tells us. And that is a good thing